ich bin ja hier gut eine kleine ja
dieser mann ist eine wahre natur gebaut
seine texte ebenso abgründig wie seine
biografie seit über 30 jahren ist endo
anaconda der kopf und das herz der
legendären schweizer band stiller aus
der zeit wäre auf tournee mit dem
allerletzten album und stattdessen sitzt
er mir aber jetzt gegenüber herzlich
willkommen in dortmund genannt
ja jetzt die schweiz lebt er seit sieben
wochen im krisenmodus wie sieht das
leben in der krise für sie ganz
persönlich
es ist ein seltsamer zustand es ist
etwas wie ein ahnungsvoll stillstand
wirklich ich würde es gar nicht dass
depression beschreiben ich will das
beschreiben als wie eine verlangsamung
des stoffwechsels deshalb fast fast
etwas meditativ buddhistisches oder fest
ob sie das buch und carlos castaneda die
lehren des london kennen wort beschreibt
wo mittels bedrohte diesen diese diesen
zeit stillstand ich empfinde das so als
zeit stillstand eigentlich aber sie
haben gesagt depression als es nicht
beglückend es so was dazwischen
wie geht es ihnen ich bemühe mich dass
die ausschläge nicht so groß hin es ist
natürlich sage ist vielleicht ein
ahnungsvoll depression aber andererseits
auch ein moment wo man über sachen
nachdenkt um irgendwie persönlich weiter
kommt wie man wie man die welt anschaut
was vermissen sie am meisten bitte was
vermissen sie am meisten die menschen
die musik die bühne meine kinder zu
umarmen und meine freundin zu treffen
zum beispiel das ist jetzt vier wochen
dann habe ich die nicht mehr gesehen
und die kinder eigentlich nur so vom
gartenzaun aus halo ist papier
es ist ein seltsames gefühl aber ich
denke man merkt schon dass das der
mensch das dass wir dass wir auf eine
art angewiesen sind auch auf körperliche
nähe auf empathie auf zärtlichkeit im
weitesten sinn sie kontakt das
menschlichen kontakt und sie leben jetzt
ja ganz allein mental seit einigen
jahren schon in einem bauernhaus
wie ist es damit der einsamkeit
ich bin zwischendurch eigentlich sehr
gern alleine also ich es ist auch so ist
ich kann nicht gut an einem ort alleine
sein das emmental das war immer für mich
so ein bisschen im fluchtpunkt und das
liegt vielleicht daran dass ich als ich
im internet waren tagen fertig war in
einem katholischen internat und wenn man
dann mit zwölf halbwüchsigen boden quasi
in einem schlafsaal schläft dann dann
lernt man das alleinsein sogar das
schätzen
ja also sich generell mühe mit mit
großen gruppen mit gruppendynamik und
die stadt von dem her auch glaube ich
ein gestörtes verhältnis zu sorgen mit
mit gruppendynamischen sachen kann ich
nicht umgehen als solche situationen
danach kann ich nicht wenn mich jemand
schief anschaut und das muss gar nicht
wenn er sein kann ich nicht einschätzen
ist er jetzt schlecht drauf oder hat er
was gegen mich oder so das ist wirklich
mein problem also vielleicht mache ich
ja auch wegen den das was ich jetzt 30
jahre gemacht habe
wegen vielleicht steht wegen dem auf der
bühne das ist durchaus möglich sie haben
ihre kinder angesprochen sie haben drei
kinder von drei frauen ja auch die band
konstellation hat sich immer mal wieder
geändert sie beschreiben sich selbst als
beziehungsunfähig sogar woher rührt dass
diese diese scheu das hängt sicher mit
meiner jugend zusammen die war schon
über weite strecken auch traumatisch
oder so deswegen an mit dem tod von
vater und dann mit diesen katholischen
internat und endlich mal geht das nicht
ausführen aber was ich natürlich wenn
man dann der tod des vaters doch dadurch
waren sie von einer völliger
kulturwechsel eigentlich aufgewachsen in
der schweiz also mein vater waren bilder
der stadtpolizist und und das war der
sanfteste mensch den ich überhaupt
tatsächlich kannten das nicht so
prügelstrafe und der war polizist und
der wollte er nicht mehr am abend nach
hause kann seine kinder verprügeln also
dass ganzen tag nur steht so ein neben
mir und der hat eigentlich immer nur
gelacht und dann kann man nach
österreich und das ganze andere kultur
die die damals war kärnten das war
stockkonservativ katholisch und die
meinten wirklich dass es erhöhe das
denkvermögen wenn man leicht geschrieben
auf sind haupt so haben sie noch
erinnerungen nach dem tod des vaters
damals waren sie vier ja dass das war
eigentlich eines der schlimmsten momente
werde ich war mit meiner mutter alleine
zu hause meine zweifel wie waren sie mit
den großeltern nach österreich sie
wollten dort die weihnachtsferien
verbringen und die besuchen und ich war
allein mit der mutter dort und gekriegt
der intern anruf stunden lang allein mit
ihnen und die das komplette dir komplett
die fassung verloren und war als
vierjähriges kind stefanies vertrauen
weil ich habe gar nicht gewusst um was
es geht wie hat sie ist wirklich total
verzweifelt und und dann ist dann
schließlich jemand gekommen
aber ich denke mit vier jahren das kann
das nicht realisieren was ist der tod
ich war dann größer aufgeben oder das
hat ja ein kommt er endlich wieder das
ist so gemein dass er nicht nach hause
kommt und die mutter die ging dann
zurück nach kärnten einem autounfall
muss man vielleicht machen wir ja da
kann ich verstehen uns an das damals für
autos also das ist ja mit eine kleine
entwickler eine karambolage gehabt und
dann warten oder die aktive kopfstützen
noch airbag und so das gab es alles
nicht und dann ist die mutter zurück
nach österreich weil sie war zwar
schweizer erinnerte schweizers als witwe
war das dann einen vormund gekriegt und
das hat man mit meiner alten dame nicht
machen können da war es jedoch sehr
stolz ja auch sehr tüchtig eigentlich
dann außer in dieses katholische
konservative kärnten ja österreich und
dagegen sie dann mit zwölf glaube ich in
dieses internat nachrechnen möglich und
da gab es hat dann diese schläge und
diese enge das war das war ja also das
war denke ich das wahlsystem mit diesen
prügelstrafen dort und das war ein
gewalt system eigentlich auch unter den
unter den zugängen
also das war nicht nur von den erziehern
zu den zu den inhaftierten quasi sondern
auch dieses prinzip auch einfach vom von
den zwillingen untereinander sie haben
gesagt da wo der insel da würdigen der
glaube ausgebrütet haben sie gesagt war
ich heute klar okay was haben sie heute
weniger behörden reagieren
was haben sie heute für ein verhältnis
zur religion ja ich bin gott also ein
siebeneinhalb milliarden
ich sehe das so nicht also wir haben das
für den höheren menschlichen geist würde
und ich finde finde seine eine
großartige leistung wenn menschen ein
höheres wesen imaginieren zählen das war
wahrscheinlich auch wichtig für unsere
entwicklung vom vom steppen renner
heute ist es nicht mehr so machen wir
das bitte heute ist es nicht mehr
wichtig diese fiktion
ja ich denke ich denke man darüber nach
aber aber das wird den glauben also
vielleicht der public sector gesagt wenn
und es dort nicht gäbe man müsste ihn
erfinden aber jetzt nicht glauben das
ist vielleicht eine ähnliche
ausgangslage in einem stück auf dem
neuen album das heißt also niemand da
singen sie niemand kommt aus dem leben
lebendig raus niemand kommt ins paradies
wenn der akku unten ist bleibt nur die
wahrheit von der liebe vom gebären vom
sterben und vom leben auf dieser erde
das ist aus gips nicht so was wir einen
höheren sinn des ganzen
ja ich glaube jeder mensch hat schon
eine seele also aber ich denke dass das
ist das was wir gewesen sind was wir
sind und was wir sein werden das ist die
menschliche seele und finden wenn wir
als auch ich bin kulturpessimist oder
wenn wenn wir so weitermachen dann
verlieren wir auch die seele weil unsere
seele ist ja auch dass wir eine
geschichte haben mit nt hat ja das hat
der richter bewusst seite kennt
geschichtsbewusstsein und der mensch hat
ein geschichtsbewusstsein was für mich
sehr wichtig ist weil ich ein
geschichtenerzähler bin und wenn wir uns
selber auslöschen
niemand die geschichte nicht einmal die
geschichte unserer blödheit erzählen und
auch nicht unsere großartigkeit nicht
oder mensch das ist eine tragik komitee
für mich das lehrers hat dabei des
jahres sei das ist hat er diese diese
wahnsinnige empathische leistung dass
man überhaupt
eine zivilisation kann aber dann haben
wir auch immer dieses kriegerische nicht
dass ich finde sogar das gehört zum
menschlichen wesen auch dieses
kriegerische es ist nur nicht mehr so
einfach wie früher beispiel früher haben
die barbaren gesagt römer die haben wir
wollen das nicht und bei einem
zentralstaat lebens und haben sich
gesehen aus scheiße ohne römisches recht
geht es auch nicht um den stadtteil groß
der große hat gesagt auf die pferde ein
herzliches müllsystem pax romana und
alles dieses zeug nicht und und das geht
heute nicht mehr weil wir sind nicht
mehr mit dem die hände sondern die die
die spielzeuge wie wir hätten zum teil
sie sind zu gefährlich das ist das
absurd wenn wenn der presse wenn der
französische präsident sagt er möchte
mit atombomben also mit atomwaffen
europa besitzen
ich meine das ist nicht konsequent durch
gedacht weil man weiß plutonium strahlt
30.000 jahre und ich finde atomkrieg das
würden wir nicht überleben oder
vielleicht ganz einzelne kleingruppen
objektivierten dann wahrscheinlich
rekrutieren zum aber das ist so die vom
faustkeil wieder oder und dass das kann
es ja nicht sein aber also die die
gefährliche tragische seite am menschen
am leben aber es gibt ja noch so die
komische die lächerliche seiten ihren
text nach immer wieder kommt sind ja
voll von dieser ironie vom sarkasmus
wie ist das ihre ihre haltung das leben
sozusagen erträglich zu gestalten indem
man diesen blick aufsetzt und und das
lächerliche in euren augen sieht auch
das absolute vielleicht nein das sichert
das was milch
was mich versöhnt mit mitglied mit
dieser mit dieser eigenschaft des
menschen kriegskurs dann auch sind das
ist auf der einen seite dass das ja auch
das gute haben das edle und das wie
komisch sind dass ihr komisch und weil
die meisten katastrophen passieren ja
nicht weil die technik schlecht ist das
ja blödsinn
es ist die katastrophen passieren weil
irgendein idiot am drücker ist dass er
die meisten unglücke auf dieser welt sei
denn es sind kosmische unfälle wo irgend
ein meteorit trifft aber alles andere
haben wir uns selber eingebrockt
das ist ja und man kann ja eigentlich
auch nicht sagen es sei schlechter
geworden also es ist nur gefährlicher
geworden
ich denke es ist gefährlicher geworden
und wir arbeiten dran dass es noch
komplexer wird dass er was sich das
darstellen soll also politik ist wie
mikado oder ich meinte nur den falschen
hebel drückst dann gibt's
erschütterungen und die spielzeuge sind
so gefährliche spiele ich so gefährlich
dass wenn irgendein idiot den falschen
hebel drückte gibt es massiv
erschütterungen und die ökonomie ist
monopoly das sagt ja immer player wurde
was dieser player
das ist casino mentalität und auch das
wort wettbewerb das stört mich
wettbewerb heißt es ist eigentlich reine
glückssache konkurrenz ist okay oder
konkurrenz sagte das befreit die
produktivkräfte dass prinz intellektuell
und in ihrer beziehung weiter weil
konkurrent heißt dass jemand falsch
denkt oder etwas falsches macht und
aufgrund seiner falschen haltung kann
man es richtig machen was meistens auch
nicht richtig ist wenn man immer quer
denken muss das ist das ist also wichtig
dass es philosophen hätte nicht wir sind
jetzt
was schön also ich schweife jetzt aber
was schön ist an der jetzigen situation
das finde ich dass wir eine regierung
haben und daniel koch dass der sagt wo
es langgeht
es bildet sich nicht irgendwer ein
vielleicht ein frachter unternehmen hat
er versteht ist ganz klar die verstehen
sind keine rolle was also aber die
demokratie sagt müssen mal abgesetzt für
eine zeit jetzt also die wir sorgen
jetzt die die die vorschläge und die
maßnahmen einhalten und erstmal geht es
nicht darum dass wir etwas mitbestimmen
sondern es wird gesagt was wir tun sie
ja ich denke wenn das schiff am kenntnis
gibt es keine diskussion
sie ist muss man muss man zuerst den
kahn stabilisieren und ich bin mit
diesem wirtschaftssystem und überhaupt
nicht einverstanden
aber ich verstehe auch dass man schauen
muss das nicht dass man nicht das kind
mit dem bade ausschütten und auch wenn
es falsch ist dass wir zu land baden hat
lassen obwohl das kind schon blaue
lippen und verschrumpelt hat und das
badezimmer unter wasser steht kamen
nicht das kind mit der wanne ausschütten
und dann dieser situation denkt sich
sind ist auch unsere regierung der
sicherlich behörde leute die wissen auch
dass es andere probleme gibt und kids
ist das erste mal eigentlich dass man
quasi dass die klientel interesse gebe
man aus weil es für alle existenz
bedrohen die einspritzung sie sind ein
wacher beobachter dass das zeit
zeitgeschehens bestens informiert sie
denken und sprechen und melden sich auch
immer wieder zu wort wenn es um
tragödien geht die in der welt passieren
um das elend und so mich interessiert
noch ein bisschen das persönliche jetzt
am anfang wie sie damit umgehen sie
haben mal gesagt sie haben keinen filter
also wenn sie irgendwo
vom elend mitbekommen dann kommen eben
manchmal die tränen wie wie grenzen sie
sich ab wenn sie das
die miserablen zustände in der welt
immer vorabend haben
ich habe mich durch die miserablen
zustände vor ort also die aber sie ist
tatsächlich so wie wir klar mensch und
und das ist psychiater ein borderline
syndrom attestierte
ich kann wirklich alles was ich kann
nicht immer sagen wenn ich da die alten
leute sehen im altersheim die da
eingesperrt sind kann ich mit einfügen
und und wenn ich gewählt habe grenze zu
griechenland oder der türkei bekommen
mehr und ich sehe dort die kinder da
kommt mir das weinen und das ist
glücklich dass die menschen meine kinder
sieht oder sieht wie die kinder haben
sie in einer frau gehabt haben dass
vereine und aber wer kümmert sich um die
männer zum beispiel das ist auch so was
machen sie wenn sie wenn sie da die die
melancholie parks oder der der blues
packen sie das runterzieht
ja da packten wir ich mein siebeneinhalb
yards durch und versuche und das gute zu
denken und ich habe auch so ablasshandel
spende zum beispiel weil ich ja nicht
mehr in der kirche bin ich zahle keine
kirchensteuer
aber ich unterstütze regelmäßig amnesty
international und und ärzte ohne grenzen
ich finde ich ihn über all das kann man
nur den hut ziehen und je nach
finanziellen reserven die ich habe
ständig monatlich etwas und das ist ja
in der schweiz ist sie zufrieden wir
eigentlich sind wir in der wellness zone
oder wir sind eigentlich die wm in der
schweiz also der held der welt wir durch
das rund
er kommt es fast wie wie dann kommt das
fast wie scheinheilig vor man kann auch
sagen wir haben ja die hälfte des mannes
gefragt und nicht 100 franken alle
monate oder aber wir neigen natürliche
systeme raus auch zum schlechten
gewissen und und haben dies in diesen
diesen applus gedanken also ich bin gott
ist relativ industrie
wir haben ja jetzt wählen wir grün art
haben etwas gemacht gegen die
klimaerwärmung
es hilft es hilft durchaus mit tätig zu
sein denn geben ist seliger denn nehmen
wobei ich jetzt froh bin habe ich auch
eine grundsicherung jetzt in dieser
saison muss ich sagen vom vom vater
staat aber ich begreife das stipendium
sie leben heute ja sehr gesund halten
sich fit aber das war nicht immer so
sie hatten dann in schweren zeiten auch
mal zu drogen gegriffen haben viel
alkohol getrunken früh mit lsd
angefangen mit mit heroin mit koks muss
man auch beides gleichzeitig man konnte
lesen dass sie mit 55 jahren noch mal
mit heroin angefangen haben was haben
sie gesucht in diesen in diesem rasch
hinter roche gehört natürlich zur
gesellschaft dass er wenn sich wer es
ist nur eine frage was ist legal
was ist illegal ich denke schweizer sind
tendenziell sind alkoholiker und
eigentlich ganz es auch genießen das ist
unglaublich der desktops und es hat aber
gerade also gegenüber opiaten dieses
dieses war nicht im moment überhaupt
nicht angesagt und eigentlich aber
opiate debattieren halt einem auch und
es gibt dann gibt einen gewissen schutz
es ist
es gegen was gegen den schmerz oder
gegen die überempfindlichkeit gegen denn
wie gesagt den weltschmerz oder oder
es ist scheinbare problembewältigung und
man kann sich das auch wieder ab
zunächst auch nicht man muss nicht
erleben sagen drogen nehmen also ich
möchte das auch nicht sein so alisch
verurteilen gewürzen oder so muss sagen
muss jeder für sich selber entscheiden
das will für mich ich habe genug
genommen also mir bringt es auch nicht
mehr noch nach dieser findet heute bin
ich fit leider kann ich nicht ins
fitnessstudio so macht sie in den
fernsehern dann auch wieder brühls
schrank auf aber machen gott sei dank
auch wieder zu weil kochsendungen allein
sind ja auch nicht abendfüllend aber man
nimmt einfach zogen dann noch so
natürlich wie gewöhnt man sich so einer
sucht ab ich muss ich mir dann ein zug
rostock muss ich beim sich aus dem
umfeld man muss sich aus diesem umfeld
wo diese dinge konsumiert werden radikal
rausnehmen
auch wenn man die personen mit denen man
dieses umfeld teilt gern hat das sind
für mich nicht die sozialfälle oder wo
das so sagen dass diese freundschaft
gekündigt oder wie man nicht gekündigt
habe aber peter im moment nicht
also wenn ich würde nicht an orten gehen
wo ich gefährdet denn aber wenn mich
jemand um hilfe bittet oder so es sind
meine möglichkeiten besteht die ich darf
mich einfach nicht der versuchung
ausliefern
vielleicht wenn ich 80 wert vielleicht
gar nicht mehr dann eine opium sucht
oder so einfach sein die um das kann ja
sein aber es ist eben in meiner jetzigen
lebensphasen ist es kontraproduktiv hält
nämlich auch die die gesundheit der
gezwungen hat dazu geben
muss was ändern oder oder ich verbringe
früher sind sie jetzt ohne drogen oder
war anders gefragt waren sie mit drogen
der bessere künstler oder fühlt es sich
zumindest besser an
ich habe mich nicht erinnern es ist
wirklich was also fehlt die erinnerung
an diese erinnern ja es gibt wirklich in
bezug auf gewisse dinge
das merkt man dann wenn man das drogen
bedürfnis ist gesättigt und man schaut
einen dieser berühmten dokumentarfilme
die so anfangen mit der stimmt mit der
deutschen stimme von robert de niro uns
erhält der kleine blaue planet und dann
sitzt man dort und man merkt man jetzt
kein zeitgefühl und man schaut dann
nachmittags solche dokumentationen
musikalisch untermalt und dann klingelt
das telefon nicht vergessen müssen sehen
halt ich bin froh passiert mir das jetzt
jetzt das gemerkt dass haben das hat ja
auch erinnerungen weggesprengt durch
merkte dass diese auch die meine märz
also mein gedächtnis hat nachgelassen
ich kann zum beispiel lese in dem buch
und dann hoffe ich dass etwas hängen
bleibt und man nichts hängenbleibt lese
ich es noch einmal aber vielleicht ist
das auch eine normale alterserscheinung
und ich bin froh passiert man das im
alter weil die alten dürfen eigentlich
alles die junge journalist und alten
dürfen wir die jungen die haben
heutzutage nichts zu verlieren
also wir haben alles zu verlieren wir
erhalten haben nichts zu verlieren das
ist ja dass die alten den herren und
kinder
aber wenn sie jetzt die werden sie
werden dieses jahr 65
wenn ich auf ihr leben blickt so von
außen stelle ich mir das ein intensives
leben vor
extras exzess leben am abgrund und jetzt
aber wenn sie das zu beschreiben mit
dieser drogenerfahrung klingt das erst
betäubt das leben war und dass das
jetzige leben vielleicht sogar
intensiver erst jetzt dass das letzte
jahr wo sie irgendwie nicht ohne diese
groben problematik das war nicht etwas
linear rechts was man sagt ich bin ich
nehme drogen und jetzt jetzt raus sie
zwei gramm heroin und ein gramm kokain
am tag das ist ja nicht so und es fängt
ja es fängt ja ganz sachte an oder und
dann denkt man ja so die erste dosis
heroin die hält vier tagen das ist
wunderbar das ist wunderbar aber das ist
dieses zeugt und das ist das problem
deshalb war eine wahnsinnige toleranz
also zum schluss enz ein suppenlöffel
und dann dann merkt man dass was nicht
im griff hat das finde ich nicht man ist
ja nicht in einen dauerhaften
rauschzustand
also es kommt dann aber irgendwann der
punkt wo man sie entweder hass auf die
bislang fort aber wo finden sie heute
diese intensiven extrem erlebnisse mit
der realität ist extrem genug
ich weiß nicht ruhiges alter wollte in
die hand der familie
ja sie haben ja eine frühe form dieser
dieser ekstase oder auch die rebellion
war natürlich die musik
sie hatten wir haben über das internet
gesprochen
in österreich erklären und da haben sie
heimlich radio luxemburg gehört haben
die beat musik entdeckt haben dann nach
dostojewski und darwin dazu gelesen so
verbotene bücher in diesem internat war
dann auch sozusagen die unterdrückung
der grund dafür für dieses
freiheitsliebende in ihnen hat das erst
ausgenommen ist die darwin ohne lesen
nämlich katholiken es war ziemlich
bedeckt wäre das nicht verboten
also es hat ja auch diese usa fällt weg
und so will ich hätte er nie darin
gelesen wenn ich nicht mit bestreiten
wollen
die po angriff streiten immer was weiß
ich jetzt
sonst macht man ja den zweiten nicht als
sonst
ja ich denke natürlich hat mich das dann
rebellisch gemacht das ist aber es hat
natürlich auch das ist immer was her
fragt ja immer was hätten sie anders
gemacht und so also das ist ja immer so
hypothetisch ich hätte gar nichts anders
gemacht
ich hätte ich hätte gewisser irrtümer
vielleicht nicht gemacht wenn ich den
berufsstand von heute gemacht hat hätte
aber das ist gerade verliert ist das ist
man lernt auch aus denn ich finde man
lernt aus aus aus den fehlern oder sagen
nicht fehler sondern wenn man falsche
schlüsse ziehen
ich denke man muss immer vielleicht als
jugendlicher die eigene position oder
seine position radikal durch denkt und
was gut wäre ist wenn man die
gegenposition genauso radikal durch
denkt also nur zum beispiel habe
überlegt die welt ist so kompliziert und
manchmal so hoffnungslos
rein vom intellekt endlich eigentlich
her
das kein argument in der jetzigen
situation lenken ein autoritäres regime
das einfach sagt soja auf die pferde es
ist so oder das einzige was seinem
abhält ist ist die nächstenliebe die
kultur der humor alles das was uns als
menschen ausmacht
ja das gute dann innen es nicht die
demokratie alles das was eigentlich die
kultur ist für mich unsere zivilisation
ausmacht dass wir sind ja auch alle
teams meine schauen sie sich diese
autoritären typen an
er ist wird gemacht die krise
wahrscheinlich also wenn es mir nicht so
mächtig werden werden sie erwacht nummer
deswegen findet man soll den krieg
ritualisiert ich stelle mir vor wut
hingegen trump der tramper würde glaubt
zweiter machen das visualisieren sagt
reiseführer wenn sie wenn sie die kriegs
wurden sind wie sie vorgeben sollen sie
persönlich also wieder boxen nach der
regel des marquis von queensberry
duellieren
oder hat ja sich gegenseitig auf die
fresse das geber super format die
einschaltquoten waren hoch aber die
entscheidungen müssten eigentlich das
volk und fachleute wir müssen genauso
dürfte nicht irgend etwas erzählen wenn
man keine ahnung hat da wird es dann
schwierig china gegen die usa nicht aber
ich glaube der tramp der kälte kaum peng
sagen hieß es schon ping weil der führt
natürlich nicht im florett oder bleiben
wir noch wissen bei der musik ja in den
80er jahren
kamen sie dann von österreich in die
schweiz nach bern nachdem ihre mutter
gestorben ist und haben da ende der 80er
89 stiller has gegründet zuerst aus als
du mit pauls niveau zusammen und dann
mit dem gitarristen später noch eine
scharfe schifer schafer
da gibt es verschiedene informationen
und wir schauen uns da mal ein paar
bilder an
doch unbedingt und es ist ja interessant
sobald sich natürlich eine der
intelligentesten und witzigsten typen
premier über den weg laufen aber auch
das schiff werde hieß es
ich hätte gar nicht mit jungen leuten
die linke das machen was aber haben sie
selbst komponiert und instrumente
gespielt sondern sich sie verstehen sich
als texte aus dichter oder sänger warum
und wieso sie haben oft gesangslinien
von mir einfließen lassen und beruft
sich aber auf gute sprüche von ihnen
geglaubt
das muss ich sagen der ball aber auch
auf den roman jetzt und und der ball ist
das sind alles dass das hat mir immer
eigentlich für mich war jetzt ich habe
da nie so ja da ist jetzt der beste
gitarrist aber oder das ist jetzt für
mich war mehr ist es hat jedes mal
aufgehört wenn mir so die interaktion
aufgehört habe oder wenn man die alten
witze nicht mehr hören konnte oder wenn
sie irgendwie person wirklich nicht
gestimmt hat
ich finde das kreativ der band braucht
es nicht unbedingt nur wird großen es
muss auch von den typen her stehen und
nicht weil jemand das ist für mich auch
der soziale umgang dann man muss auch
gut befreundet sein sonst steht man das
nicht nur muss ja oft auftreten nehmen
so mittelbaren dies nicht in der schweiz
weil er sich sogar für die die in der
schweiz jetzt mit schweizer denkt warum
sie müssen auch auftreten aber wenn mit
der kleinste ist von den großen
da muss man ziemlich viel auftreten und
wenn man unterhaltspflichtig ist zu drei
kinder da muss man sehr viel aus drehen
sie treten ein in kleinen sälen auf oft
und das macht es natürlich noch
schwieriger aber das noch mal zu den
text zurück würden sie sagen die guten
ideen die kreative energie kam im
zusammenspiel mit den anderen oder sind
sie da zu hause oder beim spazieren und
schreiben diese texte ihm im kopf
entsteht dass es gibt natürlich sachen
es gibt natürlich liebe beschreibt ihr
leben lang lang und es wird nie was und
dann gibt es auch diese diese das fliegt
ein eigentlich zu wenig da sage ich dann
das herz auch etwas metaphysisches ja
dass das was ist ihnen zu zugeflogen ja
einfach worte die man verwenden kann
aber man merkt moment das hat dann
musikalischen klang und man merkt erst
später hintendrein es ist ja eigentlich
ein text der auf irgendetwas genau sieht
also der balz hat ja immer die die die
theorie vertreten die lieder suchen sich
ihre zeit und ich habe das gefühl das
hängt vielleicht mitglieder mit mit
diesen gestörten verhältnis aus dass ich
habe sein persönlicher dass sie
vielleicht eine über sensibilität habe
dass ich sachen halt war nehme die
kinder luft schweren oder soda oder die
die im etat sind quasi die diese blaue
stunde oder wobei das also als künstler
ist man aber auf einer seite hat man
dieses metaphysische oder das einfach
ideen kommen bilder kommt er genau und
wissen wir die
auch mal fehler geben werde das dass man
sachen einfach gesamtheitliche wahrnimmt
dafür hat man vielleicht auch mehr
schmerzen also das will ich nicht ab
aber aber das ist vielleicht gar nicht
unbedingt ein verdienst und das lasse
ich zu aus theorie dass es das gibt dass
klaus künstler ist man immer auf
messerschneide eigentlich zwischen
aufklärung und aberglauben mehr da für
sie als künstler muss man vielleicht
metaphysiker seien aber staatsbürger
darf das nicht da muss man auf die viel
erzählen
aufklärung ist ein stichwort sie haben
mir immer gesagt aufklärung heute dass
sie sogar die subversiv was ist real der
bei all diesen irgendwelche wärme fake
news machen kann
so erwähnte drum sagt spritzt durch
desinfektionsmittel muss ich sagen die
aufs herz ist als 70 probieren sie es
zuerst um die welt vielleicht freundin
nicht und es gibt aber leute die das
ernst nehmen
das hat denen krawalle seien reden jetzt
ist auch diese verschwörungstheoretiker
und erich von däniken diese anhänger der
prä astronautik dieses ganze das heißt
in einer irrationalen zeit ist
aufklärung subversiv ihr neues album
heißt der pfadfinder und das ist auch
ein hinweis auf die junge generation die
vielleicht die aufgabe hat neue pfade zu
finden für uns als gesellschaft sie
sprechen da wahrscheinlich auch die
klima jugend ja ich hab diesen ausdruck
klima jugend nicht gerne ich werde das
natürlich nicht nehmen ein
berufsjugendlicher ich würde sagen es
ist auch in allen altersstufen
eigentlich setzt sich die erkenntnis
durch dass das eine der größten
bedrohungen ist die je auf die
menschheit zu bekommen ist
auf alle anderen auch die auf diesem
planeten leben und wer schon gefragt was
erwarten sie denn vom werk lima muss und
was erwarten die von uns also wir
hinterlassen ja ich bin in einer
komfortablen lage
eigentlich habe ich habe keine kritik
nicht wirklich nicht wirklich materielle
probleme als die materiellen probleme
gegen afrikanischen land ist das oberen
mittelstand nicht also und ich konnte
ich konnte irgendetwas machen aus dieser
missratenen kindheit eigentliche spiel
doch etwas gelungen auch für
selbstkritisch gesagt das ist alles das
ist eigentlich alles bedeutungslos man
kann nichts mitnehmen oder das auch die
erinnerung die verblasst und dann
irgendwann ist man weg aber jetzt leben
wir wieder in dieser krisenzeit carola
liegt alles lahm keine flugzeuge am
himmel
was steckt auch viel potenzial drin um
diese diese klimakatastrophe irgendwie
auch zu verhindern jetzt die jetzige
zeit sehen sie darin eine chance dass
etwas neues gutes entstehen kann irgend
einen richtungswechsel
ja ich denke wir brauchen alle es
braucht doch die konservativen
es braucht eigentlich alle es geht nicht
um links oder rechts es geht darum und
das sagt peter tomberg es geht darum wer
es kapiert oder nicht kapiert also und
die tatsachen die werden so drückend
sein dass entscheidungsträger die das
nicht kapieren die werden obsolet haben
sie einfach virtuellen welt die not groß
wird und dieses kredits eigentlich nur
darum das perfide ist da wir müssen
haben soll bevor die not wirklich groß
wert ja also die einzige hoffnung ist
eisen wie sicher dass wir alles ist
nicht ich denke denkt nicht auch etwas
virales sprache ist viral denken
man muss das richtige denken fördern und
sobald genug leute richtig informiert
sind und das richtige denken dann kann
es auch einen wandel geben
man muss sozusagen wie ich begreifen
sich als am körper auch die welt ist von
einem virus befallen ich meinte es hat
verschiedene symptome dass ein symptom
das ansteigen des meeresspiegels ein
symptom das abschmelzen der gletscher
und und der pole ist einst ein symptom
das soziale ungleichheit alles die klima
erhitzung und und die abholzung der
urwälder sind alles symptome eines
falschen denkens und das falsche denken
das ist der virus und und unsere
zivilisation ist davon erfahren für die
welt ist es ein schnupfen weil die hat
ein paar milliarden jahre zeit was ist
dieses vorauszudenken das interessiert
mich jetzt selbst corona ins tor und
assist denken nicht also das gipfelt wir
werden in dem das was in der erkenntnis
die erde wird klappt wird wird ist zu
klein
wir müssen zu den sternen das heißt wir
werden
trans humanismus das gibt's wie
digitalisieren uns werden unsterblich
fliegen das als sogar das ist sinnlos
also wer gehen will
wir gehen aber das heißt wenn das
menschliche bewusstsein unsterblich
machen kann was sie für völligen
brötchen halte und digitalisieren und so
verbraucht es weniger dings aber ich
stelle mir das schrecklich vor dass
männer in einer google- nekropole als
datensatz irgendwo hinzufliegen also das
wäre das ende der menschheit wir müssen
uns entscheiden wollen wir menschen
seien oder die datensätze noch hinter
tod keine angst mein persönlicher nicht
so ich sterben macht mir angst
das schon aber das sterben nicht nicht
sind jetzt tot ist so ungerecht und
warum ausgerechnet ich ich ich möchte
ich möchte nach dieser abschiedstournee
in den underground zwar nicht geologisch
sondern künstlerisch und ich hoffe dass
sie noch ein paar jahre habe und dann
wünsche ich mir zum sterben einen
frischen wind und einen süßen tod
akzeptiert für mich ist das nicht das
problem
müsste nicht den löffel abgeben ohne
hoffnung für die menschheit
ich finde ich bestimme vor ohne
menschheit das wäre langweilig aber sie
haben mir gesagt genannt dass dieser
virus im denken dieser wachstums
gegangen dieses dieses ewige konsumieren
und immer mehr und immer weiter und
dagegen irgendwas ein antikörper sowie
sie aber was heißt das konkret sie haben
sie wurden ja auch ansonsten grünen new
deal wie das wird in 30 gemacht hat nach
der wirtschaft jahren ist rainer hotel
ist nicht bewähren wenn er hat auf der
wirtschaftlichen seite etwas angestoßen
hat aus einer notsituation die hatten
wir diese wahnsinnige türe in diesem in
diesem mittleren westen nicht in diesem
pass thron starten und das sind
millionen verläuft das sind nach westen
geflüchtet und wahrheit nicht mehr so
wie zu anfang des 19 jahrhunderts dass
das da noch unendliche weiten waren bei
irgendwann mal sehen kalifornien und der
musste irgendetwas machen dass die das
eigentlich die zivilisation nicht
auseinanderbricht nicht und ich denke
dass sie eben das wollte ich sagen mit
dem mietauto spielt man muss um das
darum möchte ich nicht in die politik
sagte sagte also es bringt
natürlich als jugendlicher war ich auch
so aus einer vorstadt super mario nicht
diese vereinfachte form wie es kommt
alexander der große wir hauen knoten
durch und dann auf die pferde oder das
funktioniert sie sind ja eigentlich 72
der kommunistischen jugend beigetreten
hab's gelesen und sagen aber dass der
kommunismus hat sie sehr stark geprägt
geistig jeglicher hinsicht ja auch das
christentum also kommunismus auf das
kommt man ja nur man christ ist also
dass immer wenn man steuereffekte street
dass ich musste es ja nicht so zusammen
zu halten wo man zum teils der
schlimmste ist einer der guides und kiel
natürlich hat mich das geprägt da bin
ich auch dankbar das hat mir vielleicht
auch dieses dieses bild der welt als
räumlicher körper das habe ich so nicht
wahrgenommen da habe ich der erste
schock war wirklich die mondlandung mit
diesem bild wo die welt hinter dem mond
auftritt haben gelacht und der damalige
physiklehrer sonst ein harter hund
er hat gesagt das war wahnsinn
und jetzt verlassen wir die raumsonden
sich schon aus dem sonnensystem draußen
und alles nur jeder mensch dort nicht
hinfliegen
wir müssen das
wir müssen die unendlichkeit muss man
philosophisch oder religiös erobern das
geld physikalisch gar nicht das ist das
problem aber bleiben wir noch bei diesem
bild der erde als eine einheit
das ist ja wenn jetzt am gerechtigkeit
denken oder an solidarität bestimmt das
problem sie haben sie haben einmal
gesagt das proletariat wurde von der
ersten in die dritte welt ausgelagert
wie können wir denn auf globaler ebene
eine form von gerechtigkeit etablieren
haben sie da irgendwelche visionen
vorstellungen richtungen indem man
denken könnte ja das ist linke philosoph
aber aber ich denke also es ist schon
ein fortschritt ich habe jetzt
eigentlich jetzt zum beispiel also das
war ja schon eine kulturelle leistung wo
sich horden zu stemmen formiert haben
und eine gewisse zeit lang war war der
staat eigentlich weiterentwicklung nicht
aber wir haben noch zeit das bewusstsein
der horde also wir haben ja es gibt ja
soziologen nie das untersucht haben ich
weiß nicht es gibt bis zu einer gewissen
gruppe wo man empathie empfinden kann
und jetzt finde ich dass zum beispiel
auch sein punkt jetzt habe ich mich zum
ersten mal ehrlich die schweiz als staat
wahrgenommen und nicht das föderation
wird wenn hier hohe steuer nimmt dann
machen wir niedrige und schießen euch
dafür die sozialfälle oder sonnig dieses
textes plötzlich plötzliches burgfrieden
es geht um etwas und ich denke das geht
vielleicht nur aufgrund von druck von
außen
und wenn wir das jetzt schaffen das
quasi auf die globale ebene zu schaffen
ich lebe noch gar nicht vom kosmischen
sondern auf die globale ebene dass das
wird
lokal handeln dass wir verschieden sind
es lebe der unterschied aber ein
gemeinsames gemeinsamen geistigen
philosophischen überbau haben für diese
welt dann sehe ich grün und sonstigen
schwarz und ist freilich alles ist
grenzüberschreitend ich mein wenn jemand
meint das hätte keinen einfluss wenn
australien abbrennt dann ist das ein
irrtum weil weil im amazonasgebiet
verdunkelt sich verdunkelt sich der
himmel
das muss man sich vorstellen das erste
mal war das so wo das das war bei
tschernobyl das kann ich mich erinnert
das war einer dieser dieser stillstände
gehe ich schon erlebt habe es als die
lehrer gewesen in den 70er jahren war
war diese ölkrise das war der schotte
autos meine mutter den feldstecher
gebraucht dass die motor das ende der
motorhaube gesehen hast unterwegs die
ölkrise nicht dass das war so ein
stillstand und dann kam für mich dass
tschernobyl das war lustig weil er habe
in einem gemüse als einen bioladen
gearbeitet und das war die totale
verunsicherung aber es ging nicht so
lang wie corona weil die leute haben
nach zwei wochen namens schwieger kopf
salat gegessen hat noch immer gestrahlt
wahrscheinlich und das dritte reich mit
balz in deutschland haben wir
deutschland tournee gemacht dass gerade
die ddr zusammengebrochen das war auch
so einem moment irgendwie und das ist
jetzt das hat eine andere qualität
eine andere hoffnung ist dass diese
krise irgendwas grundlegend verändert
und unserem wirtschaftssystem an unserem
globalen denken an dieser vernetzung die
sie angesprochen haben die artisten wir
hoffen aber vielleicht muss man auch die
oder die einzelnen komponenten ganz
isoliert betrachten also man muss halt
das konsumdenken auch überdenken muss
unsere reise verhalten überdenken ohne
eigentlich ein lebensqualität einzubüßen
also jetzt kommt zum beispiel kommt die
neue frühlingskollektion dies aber schon
wieder überflüssig werden leben suchen
jetzt wird man lieferanten für ich weiß
nichts geschenkt hoffentlich es nimmt
jemand und dann kommt aber schon die
sommerkollektion man vielleicht kommt
der sommer gar nicht und vielleicht
sollten die leute halte etwas
konsumieren aber hohe qualität
konsumieren weil es ist ja so dass im
prinzip ein gut bezahlter verdünnter
facharbeiter nützt der welt mehr der ein
qualitätsprodukt herstellt meinetwegen
hingehen und damit eine fünfköpfige
familie ernährt bringt der welt mehr als
sechs als ein sklavenarbeit damit fünf
kinder arbeiten wo alle einfach nur die
die können gar nie aus dieser situation
rauskommen das ist jetzt nur so dass
soziale aspekt oder und wenn man schaut
die fetzen
die leute einkaufen dieses dieses
unnötige gerümpel das dann irgendwie
zurück geht an den online-händler und
der prinz in die verbrennung weil es zu
teuer ist das wieder einzupacken
ich habe sofort ja das sind absurde und
das sieht man jeden das sind auch nur
symptome und wenn wir dort und denken
können und sagen okay ich schaffe keine
plastikstreifen mir für meine füße die
mit sklaven arbeit gemacht zinsen ist
offen schöne tanne oder irgendetwas was
reparierbar ist
wir sind zu reparieren gesellschaft
zurück kommen hilft und sage ich die
digitalisierung bei diesem schritt in
eine ökologischere zukunft also jetzt in
der gegenwärtigen krisen krise hilft
sehr sicher also wir können miteinander
in kontakt bleibt sozialen austausch
pflegen telefon dank facetime
sie selbst sind ja sehr zurückhaltend
und bescheiden zusammen sie haben kein
smartphone kein kann email und wetter
nach dagegen die großen digital konzerne
wie google amazon facebook und so was
was machen sie falsch war was läuft in
die falsche richtung aus ihrer sicht
sachen digitalisierung da ist sind sind
ja alle auch straflos die laut
bürgerlichem gesetzbuch verboten sind
warum das ist völlig unkontrolliert also
sie manipulieren waren sie greifen in
sich demokratie und sie dieses medium
ist es können hass mails können hass
botschaften verbreitet werden fake news
ohne dass man den urheber angeben muss
ist völlig unkontrolliert das ist völlig
unkontrolliert und ich denke sie wissen
dass es unkontrolliert ist es gibt
keinen datenschutz
es gibt keinen datenschutz das von der
eu gibt es die datenschutz grund wenn
man sie gezwungen wird gezwungen sich in
das netz in das netz von von silicon
valley zu begeben oder ich weiß auch
nicht oder oder oder von china
man hat ja gar nicht die wahl und ich
halte das für so und sie zahlen nicht
einmal steuern
sie zeigen sich einmal steuern dort
hatte sie die wertschöpfung haben warum
soll ich gute stelle geht es dann nicht
zum roman den ich dann meine beiträge
fragen der hilfen das dann tippen
ich habe nicht funktioniert natürlich
auch über die digitalen medien
ja ich bin nicht prinzipiell
technikfeind aber ich glaube wir werden
diese diese neuen medien brauchen um in
einem sind die die das system wieder zu
dezentralisieren weil sich
herausgestellt hat diese art zu
produzieren als vernichtet uns das klima
das es lebensbedrohlich aber man könnte
mit diesen technologien das sehr gut
optimieren also ich stelle mir die
zukunft vor eine eine mischung aus
hightech und lotet das heißt das ja low
tec ist ökologische produktion die nicht
unbedingt auf profit sondern auf
mehrwert ausgerichtet das sind zwei
völlig verschiedene sachen für mich
mehrwert und profit das ist profis gerät
ins monopoly wissen es nicht und
mehrwert das ist der normale mehrwert
klein steht das menschliche arbeit
das heißt wenn wir uns natürlich
ernähren wollen oder so wenn wir den
klimawandel stoppen wollen müssen wir
zurück zur not es wenn wir das aber
gerecht verteilen neuen gebrauchten
halten sich ganz einfach so verfährt man
nicht mit leeren nach lastwagen herum
geschieht keine rohstoffe macht das
joghurt nicht in den niederlanden
geschickt was nach sizilien wird
versetzen und mit früchten und jetzt
nach frankreich nicht verpackt zum
beispiel und zum schluss schießt muss
jetzt weggeworfenen abfall container so
wie es keiner kaufen will
wissen sie was ein der gratkorner zum
schluss habe ich auch noch was was sie
gerne in den abfallcontainer meisten wir
das weiß es nämlich auf der neuen platte
geht es nämlich darum diese dinge
geranien habe ich mitgebracht was hatten
sie gegen die ich habe gar nichts
dagegen aber das ist nur dieses bild
nicht ich habe bei mir ich habe keinen
grünen daumen
aber in einem seiner songs ist dieses
heißt versionen spinnmilben und das ist
wichtig denn sie sind und diese
spinnweben
die sind für mich ein bild auch ich sehe
auch unsere eigene existenz oder wenn
man jetzt sagt das gremium ist ist eine
eigene welt ein eigener kosmos und da
drin sind die schwimm und und das ist
mir dieses bild und wir sind die spinnen
wir sind auf stehen also welches volk
unser ganzes sonnensystem auch nur ein
spiel wenn ich das ist es sehr lustig
weil gerät die bedrohung kommt von etwas
ganz ganz kleinen ich hätte das nicht
erwartet
nicht gewählt ist aber los vielleicht
sind wir die spinnmilben im universum
bringen alles irgendwie durcheinander
hoffnung ist nicht hoffen wir hoffen wir
dass wir die antikörper sind wir wissen
wie wir ehrenamtlich dem ich nicht
trainiert und brauchten die hosen nicht
mehr ändern konnte vielen herzlichen
dank franck ist ja danke ihnen fürs
mitdenken nächste woche spricht barbara
bleisch mit bertrand piccard dem
schweizer psychiater und flugpionier und
fragt was ich aus dem leben in einer
ballon kapsel für den lockdown lernen
lässt und jetzt gleich fragt die stern
schon eine kunst ob kunstwerke
eigentlich politisch korrekt sein sollen
und was das für die freiheit der kunst
bedeuten würde bleiben sie also dran und
einen schönen sonntag
[Musik]